Hello and welcome to this unusual AI Coffee
Break!
Today we’ll share with you some of our own
work, which was accepted at ACL 2022.
I know what you could think: It might not
seem like much, especially when we compare
our work with papers that we have previously
covered on the channel, coming from big companies
and many authors, but you know, we are proud
of our paper, it is honest work!
We’ll be presenting this at ACL 2022 in
the last week of May, so in case you will
be attending the ACL conference too, I guess
we’ll see you in Dublin!
Don’t hesitate to say hi if you’re around!
Otherwise, you can have a look at what we
have been working on recently, in this video.
Enjoy!
Hello!
We are happy to present our work on „VALSE”,
a Task-independent benchmark meant for testing
Vision and Language models with specific linguistic
phenomena.
Why did we do the trouble in setting up this
benchmark?
Well, during the last years, we have seen
an explosion of transformer-based vision and
language models pretrained on large amounts
of image-text pairs.
Each one of these models pushes state-of-the
art on vision and language tasks, such as
Visual Question Answering, Visual Commonsense
Reasoning, Image Retrieval, Phrase Grounding.
So, we got the message, the accuracies on
these task-specific benchmarks are increasing
steadily, but do we know what the models have
actually learned?
What is it that a vision and language transformer
“understood” when assigning a high score
for this image and this sentence to match?
And a low score for this one?
Do VL models focus on the right thing?
Or do they focus on biases as shown by previous
work?
To shed more light on this aspect, we propose
a more task-agnostic direction and introduce
VALSE that tests the sensitivity of VL models
to specific linguistic phenomena that affect
both the linguistic and the visual modalities.
We target existence, plurality, counting,
spatial relations, actions, and entity coreference.
But how do we test whether the VL models have
captured these phenomena?
By foiling, a method previously applied for
VL models only for noun phrases by Ravi Shekhar
and collaborators, and on counting, by us
in previous work.
Foiling basically means that we take the caption
of an image and produce a foil by altering
the caption such that it does not describe
the image anymore.
And we do these phrase alterations by focusing
on 6 specific pieces, such as existence, plurality,
counting, spatial relations, actions, and
entity coreference, where each piece can consist
of one or more instruments, in case we found
more than one way to create foil instances.
For example, in the case of the actions piece,
we have two instruments: one in which the
action verb is changed with a different action
and one in which actants are swapped.
Counting and coreference are also pieces that
have more than one instrument.
We create these foils by making sure that
they fail to describe the image, that they
are grammatical and otherwise valid sentences.
This is not easy to do because a foiled caption
may be less likely than the original caption:
For example, though not impossible, it is
statistically less likely for plants to cut
a man than a man to cut plants and large VL
models could pick up on this.
Therefore, to obtain valid foils, we must
take action: First, we make use of strong
language models to propose foils.
Second, we use Natural Language Inference
to filter out foils that could be still describing
the image, since when constructing foils,
we need to ensure that they fail to describe
the image.
To test this automatically, we apply natural
language inference (NLI) with the following
rationale: We consider an image to be the
premise and its caption its entailed hypothesis.
In addition, we consider the caption to be
the premise and the foil is its hypothesis.
If an NLI model predicts the foil to contradict
or to be neutral with respect to the caption,
we take this as an indicator of a valid foil.
If an NLI model predicts the foil to be entailed
by the caption, it cannot be a good foil since
by transitivity it will give a truthful description
of the image and we filter these foils out.
But this procedure is not perfect, it is just
an indicator for valid foils, therefore as
a third measure for generating valid foils,
we employ human annotators to validate the
data used in VALSE.
So, after filtering and human evaluation,
we have as many test instances as described
in this table.
Note that VALSE does not deliver any training
data, but only test data since it is a zero-shot
testing benchmark only.
It is designed to leverage the existing capabilities
of VL models after pre-training.
Fine-tuning would only enable models to exploit
artefacts or statistical biases in the data.
We all know that these models like to cheat
and take shortcuts and as we said, we are
interested in assessing what capabilities
the VL models have after pre-training.
We experiment with five VL models on VALSE,
namely with CLIP, LXMERT, ViLBERT, ViLBERT
12-in-1 and VisualBERT.
Two of our most important evaluation metrics
are: the accuracy of the models in classifying
image-sentence pairs into captions and foils.
Perhaps more relevant for this video, we will
showcase our more permissive metric, the pairwise
accuracy which measures whether the image-sentence
alignment score is greater for a correct image-text
pair than for its foiled pair.
For more metrics, do check out the paper.
The results with pairwise accuracy are shown
here and they are consistent with the results
we got with the other metrics.
The best zero-shot performance is achieved
by ViLBERT 12-in-1, followed by ViLBERT, LXMERT,
CLIP and finally VisualBERT.
It's notable how instruments centered on individual
objects like existence and noun phrases are
almost solved by ViLBERT 12-in-1, highlighting
that models are capable of identifying named
objects and their presence in images.
However, none of the remaining pieces can
be reliably solved in our adversarial foiling
settings.
We see from the plurality and counting instruments
that VL models have trouble distinguishing
references to single vs. multiple objects
or counting them in an image.
The relation piece shows that they have difficulties
in correctly classifying a named spatial relation
between objects in an image.
They also have trouble distinguishing actions
and identifying their participants, even if
supported by plausibility biases, as we see
in the actions piece.
From the coreference piece we find out that
tracing multiple references to the same object
in an image by using pronouns is also difficult
for VL models.
As a sanity check and also because it is an
interesting experiment, we also benchmark
two text-only models: GPT1 and GPT2 to assess
whether VALSE is solvable by these unimodal
models by computing the perplexity of the
correct and foiled caption and predicting
the entry with the lowest perplexity.
If the perplexity is higher for the foil,
we take this as an indication that the foiled
caption may suffer from plausibility bias
or other linguistic biases.
It is interesting to see, that in some cases,
the text-only GPT models have captured the
plausibility of the world better than the
vision and language models.
To sum up, VALSE is a benchmark that uses
the lens of linguistic constructs to help
the community improve V&L models by hard testing
their visual grounding capabilities.
Our experiments show that V&L models identify
named objects and their presence in images
well (as shown by the existence piece), but
struggle to ground their interdependence and
relationships in visual scenes when forced
to respect linguistic indicators.
We would really like to encourage the community
to use VALSE for measuring progress towards
language grounding with V&L models.
Even more, VALSE could be used as an indirect
assessment of datasets, as models could be
evaluated before and after training or fine-tuning
to see if a dataset helps models improve on
any of the aspects tested by VALSE.
If you’re interested, do check out the VALSE
data on GitHub and if you have any questions,
do not hesitate to contact us!